sie sind gut ausgebildet sie sind sehr
erfahren sie arbeiten seit jahren in
diesem beruf aber auch dass hier hat sie
keiner vorbereitet wie auch
krankenschwester wie mancher matthew
wachsen über sich hinaus tag für tag in
jedem augenblick da sind so viele die
jetzt rund um die uhr ihre hilfe
brauchen damit sie atmen können sich
mancher und die anderen keine atempause
der krankenhausalltag ist immer hart
jetzt verlangt er ihnen noch mehr ab
übermenschliches fasst die angehörigen
flehen uns an bitte rettet unsere
liebsten sie sagen ihr seid wie gott für
uns das geht einem so nah wir tun doch
nur was wir können
es geht immer um leben und leichte fälle
haben sie ihr nicht die luft blatt weg
die atmung setzt aus viel zu oft geht
der kampf verloren und die helfer
könnten selbst hilfe brauchen manchmal
breche ich einfach zusammen wache nachts
wein und auf der anderen seite gibt mir
meine arbeit ein gutes gefühl weil ich
etwas tue weil ich alles versuche
lebensgefährlich ist dieser job
keiner weiß besser als sie wie schlecht
die chancen stehen wenn man sich
infiziert
zu hause warten ein mann und drei kleine
kinder
mancher hat was wohl jeder in der hat
angst delhis straßen sind voll mit
menschen die hier nicht sein sollten
kranke die auf eine intensivstation
gehören aber dort keine betten kein
platz kein sauerstoff coaching sagt er
könne das alles kaum ertragen man müsste
doch was tun und er tut was
wenn das leben eines menschen nur an
einem seidenen faden hängt dann müssen
wir wenigstens versuchen diese menschen
irgendwie zu helfen
sauerstoff organisieren wo immer sich
was auftreiben lässt sind sie dabei der
schwarzmarkt blüht die preise horrend
die bestände bleiben knapp erholen sich
die werte bei einem kranken geht die
flasche sofort zum nächsten weiter
hunderte kommen jeden tag zu uns wenn
uns die regierung hier helfen würde
könnten wir viel mehr retten
die regierung aber gesteht noch nicht
mal offiziell ein dass sauerstoffmangel
herrscht spricht nur von
transportproblemen oder sogar
verschwenderisch im einsatz
nichts davon passt mit der traurigen
wirklichkeit zusammen
lange zeit waren gut durch die pandemie
gekommen
ein harter lockdown vor einem jahr
brachte zwar wirtschaftliche not aber
corona schien im griff die regierung
erklärte das virus für besiegt
das war eine totale fehleinschätzung
aufgrund der signale wie die regierung
ausgesendet hat wir hätten den kampf
gewonnen haben die bundesstaaten
tatsächlich ihre krone einrichtungen
gesundheitszentren isolierstationen die
in der ersten welle aufgebaut wurden
wieder geschlossen
leicht sind machte sich breit mit dem
segen der regierung warteten millionen
gläubige hindus gerade erst im ganges da
war das virus längst schon wieder auf
dem vormarsch und auch wahlen wurden
abgehalten wissen wie wahlen den medien
nun mal aussehen
das ergebnis ein denkzettel für die
regierungspartei sicher auch wegen ihrer
corona politik aber wenn die opposition
das feiert dann eben wieder ohne abstand
ohne maske mit risiko
dem premierminister persönlich halten
viele für verantwortlich nach den drei
modi der zuletzt eine erstaunliche
optische wandlung durchmacht die weißen
haare werden länger der bart wächst da
entsteht ein bild das zunehmend an einen
religiösen führer erinnert der über den
politischen dingen schwebt auch über der
pandemie
das hat für ihn gut funktioniert er ist
wie eine marke geworden hat ein image
aufgebaut aber jetzt wenn die menschen
wenn das ganze land mitten im
überlebenskampf steckt ist so ein image
doch eher schäbig fadenscheinig ball
bier hat seinen glauben verloren sein
sohn ist tot er wurde 27 jahre alt
hinterlässt ein vier monate altes kind
wie soll man bier wie soll ein mensch
das fassen
keiner hat was unternommen es ist alles
so furchtbar er hatte einfach keinen
sauerstoff
mein sohn ist in meinen armen gestorben
ein junge ist tot
stundenlang hat bei wir hier gewartet
bis eine feuerstelle im krematorium frei
wurde und dann muss alles ganz schnell
gehen denn die nächsten toten werden
gebracht es ist fast wie am fließband
die tender bestattet jeden tag mehr als
100 menschen zu hause hat er frau und
tochter beide sind mit corona infiziert
aber er sagt er müsste ich ja
weitermachen
für die toten und ihre hinterbliebenen
nicht nur menschen sterben
es stirbt auch die menschlichkeit
ambulanzen etwa verlangen inzwischen
absurde preise damit sie die toten
überhaupt her bringen das sollte nicht
sein
sie kommen hier einfach nicht nach
inzwischen fehlt es den krematorien
sogar schon an holz 3 4000 tote tag für
tag indiens offizielle corona bilanz ist
der blanke horror aber sehr
wahrscheinlich ist alles noch viel
schrecklicher ich schätze dass 50
prozent der toten gar nicht offiziell
gezählt werden
die regierung zählt in ihrer corona
bilanz nur die aus den krankenhäusern
nicht die die zu hause sterben und von
freiwilligen heer gebracht werden
traumatische bilder apokalyptische
szenen die sich einbrennen
sie gehen von indien aus in die welt wie
eine mahnung dieses virus ist die hölle
[Musik]